Kiet Nguyen: Hello, guys.
Kiet Nguyen: Today, we are going to talk about a lot of things.
Kiet Nguyen: That is… Okay, so let me turn on the script.
Kiet Nguyen: Mmm, traps. Deep. Heavy.
Kiet Nguyen: Not the wolf.
Kiet Nguyen: Too big for that. Whatever it is, it's been here recently.
Kiet Nguyen: Geralds pauses, crouching by broken branches. Glow marks on the bark.
Kiet Nguyen: Widespread leashing, maybe, or something that wants me to think it's a legend.
Kiet Nguyen: He rises, hand on his sewer sword.
Kiet Nguyen: Winds changing, smell of throat and blood.
Kiet Nguyen: Fresh. Damn, whatever, I'm hunting, it's close.
Kiet Nguyen: He glances at the dark tree line. Could wait until morning. Less risk. But villagers don't have until morning. Guess I don't either.
Kiet Nguyen: Garrett.
Kiet Nguyen: Smirks faintly, shaking his head. Another night, another master, and they wonder why I'm so foreign to Abrams.
Kiet Nguyen: Okay, so it is the end of… the dialogue.